yo what's up my name is damon calling
you i live in
everett washington dirty damon up there
outside of everett
and i'm sorry for calling you damon but
dirt sometime with damon they say dirty
damon
you know like claude they say clean
clawed
but they don't say clean damon on we're
brother
um 23 years old uh
i just had a quick question so i wanted
to get your opinion on something
my girlfriend and i have been trying to
spice things up in the bedroom you know
oh yeah brother send pics
just joking don't write an article about
that some creep
um yeah brother i feel you man look
when i was 23 baby doing sex was really
god i mean i felt like i was just
sunbathing on the lord's front porch bro
i mean i just felt like my whole body
[ __ ] knew just
was made out of damn just penis
meat man i was just so you were just so
excited and fired up
god remember that i remember somebody
would just accidentally bump into me and
if
if she was cute i'd damn you know
i'd dampen that leg baby you feel me
onward baby let's hear more brother
thank you for calling man
praise god it's been a while we've been
going at it for a while
and time to try some new things so she
suggested
that we come up with different
characters and act like we're cheating
on each other
but uh the problem is is i'm not very
good at this i mean
i come up with characters and i i either
break character
or i just i don't know don't know what
to say and i think it's been
it's been a while since i've been in the
games you know
hurting and trying to pick up girls
isn't really strong
but uh her she's really good at it i
mean
she's coming up with characters names
right off the bat
playing them really well and i don't
know i just want to be able to give her
what she's given me
so if you got any advice for me uh i
would love it
uh thanks for all you do man love the
podcast gang
see you later bro thank you man um
and thank you for the call and for
asking me uh
i mean that's that's first of all that's
exciting
you're involved in an exciting world
where you guys are
you know dressing up and doing um
different pos
you know positions or something or
whatever you know
costume and all of that that's that
booty halloween when they say let's get
you know why don't you do this or do
that
and it's kind of the one time i feel
like if you want to do
i wouldn't say if you want to kind of go
a little brown face you might be able to
do it in that instance
you know if it's just you and your girl
and you want to really kind of
explore some sexual
you know adventures
you know you do something i'm not saying
you know
get racial but i'm saying you know maybe
some nest cafe or something on the
cheeks a little bit of uh
you know i think you could go at least a
mocha
and you know my name is no dante my name
is you know
uh you know corinthian or something you
know you could do
like you could do a role play like that
so it kind of gives you a chance to
[Music]
learn about other cultures you could
read up on some of
you know a certain culture's history a
black history if you wanted to if you
want to go black and
you know just approach your girl maybe
you know everything we've been through
that kind of stuff
and at least have like a
you know have put on some
poetic justice or something in the
background or like a um
save the last dance or something or
dances with wolves i'm trying to think
of like a good kind of racially
movie that permit promotes like um
[Music]
you know racial love you know
so that could be something
uh you could do
swedish you know swedish is kind of easy
you get a thing of milk
a pail of milk and then you run over
there and you all kind of [ __ ] a little
but i'm trying to think of something you
could do that would be more historical
you could maybe do native american
you know and she's like a white woman
and you
you know sneak in or something sneak in
the window
you know you you know you don't attack
or you you know you tell you leave her a
note or something says i'ma attack you
you know plan ahead but you don't just
you don't just
you know not call for a couple days and
then
swing out of the damn cabinets you can't
be like indian in the cupboard you got
to be
you know indian in the closet who left a
note
but i would go full throttle because if
anything the one thing it's going to do
this whole thing is just gonna create
comfortability
so many guys would love for their wife
or their you know fiance their french
wife or whatever
to do a wig you know to do us
you know you know that crotch wig that
strap on or probably not that but they
would love for their wife to do
something unique
but he's afraid to say it they're just
afraid to say hey honey
put on the green wig borrow wanda's
[ __ ] wig
so for seven seconds of my life it could
you know feel could feel that that vibe
like i'm getting up in that ufo you feel
me praise god man but
also you could um what am i thinking
about
i'm just saying and what you if you're
starting to create communication dude
that's fire
because then you guys gonna be able to
do anything
so many of us were just afraid to talk
and say this or say that
or afraid of the judgment or what they
gonna think or they're gonna tell people
but man to live outside of that fear
and to dress up like the damn
you know like saving private ryan or
whatever
or to you know dress up like damn uh
jean-claude van damme you and your girl
dress up like karate man or something
you know and just kick each other till
you ejaculate you know there's just
you gotta think big picture fam
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one